ali what do you say to the women that  say my husband isn't my boss there is no  need to be submissive you're a team  i understand where they're coming from  but these same women don't understand  that oftentimes they'll put their  husbands on the back burner for like an  actual boss in real life that they have  to submit to and they constantly ask  their husbands to modify their lives for  that meanwhile the dude is forgotten  he's absolutely sexless and she's  feeding him out of the microwave that's  the problem if you can work and love  your man equally you want to talk about  equalism right if you can do that then  good but most women can't most women  can't even push the power button on an  air fryer